mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
reisen endlich wieder in die ferne
schweifen
doch wie kehren wir zurück zum
massentourismus
oder werden wir zum individual
abenteurer wie geht reisen in der
zukunft nordkorea eine diktatur völlig
isoliert vom rest der welt und doch es
gibt ähnlichkeiten zur schweiz unterwegs
in einem land der berge und im hotel
waldhaus wohl bera traf sich im letzten
jahrhundert die hochfinanz mit dem
glamour zur kur bis 1989 abgelehnte
gerettet wurde ein geheimnis das jetzt
gelüftet wird
[Musik]
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ja heute
gehen wir der kultur des reisens nach
und haben uns dafür für ein gefährt
entschieden das maximale freiheit
verspricht der wohnwagen allerdings sind
wir damit auch maximal den launen der
natur ausgesetzt und das bekommen wir
heute so richtig zu spüren
ja was reisen seit klimawandel und zeit
der pandemie ganz grundsätzlich bedeutet
dieser frage gehen wir heute nach
[Musik]
bevor ich losfahre treffe ich mich mit
dem mann der mir einen oldtimer
wohnwagen ausleiht und alles übers
kempen weiß
[Musik]
heiligendamm sie restaurieren alter
campari mit aussehen ganz viele woher
und der liga schafften die jetzt schon
früh mit dem auto in die ferien besucht
wurde zum auto passte und hat sich
einfach inhalte wohnlage kaufte
restauriert
im wohnpark und maxi camp ihr das
bedeutet aus sicht der naturschützer das
habe mir dazu jetzt spüre über haben sie
die ente oder andere anekdote
risikobereit es kommt man im winter und
der kassier alt werden jetzt sagen wir -
56 und dennis war 2001 alte lee yung
möglich aber mit der heizung ist das gar
nicht so schlecht
man dankt ich glaube das maximale
freiheit hat war mal mit dem wohnwagen
oder mit dem camper ich das wirklich
außer es geht ihm so und reden schweizer
durch das neue illusionen schöne traum
natürlich würde zeige der letzten 15
jahre stark verändert
die wiener boden entstanden so weiter im
wohnmobil werke verkauft aber gefiel mir
campingplatz gibt es wahrscheinlich
nicht was sie weiter immer voller und
das abend kurzfristig verloren
genau das will die kombi kämpferisch
eigentlich verboten aber waren leber
buch in dem sie nie wissen zur verfügung
stellt sich dass man das lösen
kommen jetzt ein amerikaner aus klasse
was hat denn der amerikaner soll später
in sachen statik der hat jetzt nicht so
viel später wird eigentlich das land
stehe ich auf der linie die größere die
duschen eigentlich allen luxus kann man
sich durch zu hause können wünsche er
hat einfach das badezimmer und das wc
und es hat nicht original ausgerichtet
wurde
[Musik]
also nix wie los unterwegs sein ist ja
bereits die halbe miete sogar bei diesem
wetter mein ziel einen idyllischen ort
in der natur zu finden und dort einen
moment zu verweilen und darüber zu
sinnieren wie sich die kultur des
reisens angesichts von pandemie und
klimawandel wohl für immer verändert hat
[Musik]
träumen sie von ferien am meer
sehnen sich nach entspannung und
erholung wünschen sich weit weg von
allen sorgen ängsten problemen
doch wo und wie lässt sich unbeschwert
urlaub machen in zeiten wie diesen
und in zukunft
wie viel hat reisen eigentlich mit dem
guten leben zu tun und was ist für mich
gutes leben
sie können natürlich gerne nach gegner
fahren und dort an den strand und
schauen wie das gefühl ist zusammen mit
vielen vielen vielen anderen
schweizerinnen und schweizern das wird
super
der historiker valentin groebner hat
noch vor corona ein buch übers wegfahren
und wegfliegen geschrieben über unsere
nimmermüde suche nach dem perfekten
urlaub er kennt kein pardon wenn es um
den ferien zirkus geht das ist ja eine
große selbstverpflichtung maschine und
plötzlich ist die zum stillstand
gekommen die seit 170 jahren gelaufen
und wir stellen auf einmal fest geht
auch ohne
so ist müdigkeit für brückner sind
ferien großteils eine anti überdruss
maßnahme gegen den eigenen alltag ist
verreisen wirklich ein akt der
verzweiflung verpackt als belohnung ein
reisen ist viel mehr reisen ist welt
erkundung weltverständnis
herausforderung wachsen lernen all das
es reisen für erik lorenz autor und
erfolgreicher podcaster ist jeder
zurückgelegte kilometer eine nachhaltige
erfahrung in seinem buch welt wach
erzählt er von seinen eigenen abenteuern
und lebens lektionen
vom motorrad trip durch den himalaja der
ihn mut zum wagnis gelehrt habe von
vorstellungen die es galt über bord zu
werfen
in einem dorf in laos auf einer
verlotterten farm in australien oder im
iranischen isfahan
selbst wenn man das gefühl hat oder
meint relativ weltoffen durch die gegend
zu gehen
man hat eben doch oft vorurteile
denkmuster handlungsmuster zu
durchbrechen fällt im alltag wahnsinnig
schwer das zu lernen kann beim reisen
für leichter gelegen weil man dann schon
fast automatisch aus seinen üblichen
abläufen und denkprozessen
herausgenommen ist muss man um den
globus sausen um voranzukommen zu
wachsen
für valentin groebner kein probates
allerwelts mittel die veränderung auf
reisen gibt und zwar wenn man 19 21 25
ist da passiert wahnsinnig viel auf
reisen wenn ich mit 50 weg war
wiederholt was aber ich kann mir selber
ein reden oder mein reisebüro tut er's
dass das ganz neue erfahrungen sind
erfahrungen macht man dadurch dass man
dinge lernt und ich glaube dass die
wesen die meisten erfahrungen macht man
eigentlich dadurch dass man dinge
ausprobiert und arbeitet und reisen ist
das genaue gegenteil von arbeit
es sei denn es ist die eigene arbeit zu
reisen
diese reduktion greife zu kurz jede
generation könne aus zwei drei wochen in
der fremde wertvolle lehren ziehen
voraussetzung echtes interesse an land
und leuten
aber wenn ich einmal dagewesen bin
nämlich an gerüche in einem menschen den
ich begegnet bin dann wirklich eine ganz
andere partie
wenn ich zum beispiel eine schlagzeile
lesen über irgend eine politische krise
oder einer naturkatastrophe und ich
finde ich diesen orten einfach viel mehr
verbunden und habe dadurch auch das
gefühl dass ich ein stück weltbürger
werde auf die schnelle die welt
entdecken und sich erholen
schier unmöglich erst recht keine lösung
eine pauschalreise da sind sich lorenz
und grüttner für einmaleins der
erholungs und erlebnis stress sei
vorprogrammiert ebenso die enttäuschung
überhöhte erwartungen zu glauben bei so
einer reise das einzigartige unberührte
zu finden
bei weltweit 1,5 milliarden touristen im
jahr
selbstbetrug auch sehenswürdigkeiten
abzuklappern habe mit welt kennenlernen
wenig zu tun die ihnen die bis februar
letzten jahres nach luzern gekommen sind
stehen an denselben orten und schauen
sich dieselben sachen an wie mark twain
und james fenimore cooper im neunzehnten
jahrhundert das heißt das ist eine große
rückkopplung maschine wo bilder die alle
leute schon kennen dazu dienen selber
hin zu fahren und sie sich nochmal
anzuschauen an touristenorten entsteht
nichts neues reisen damit alles so
bleibt wie es ist keine
zukunftsperspektive beim reißen sollten
wir unsere komfortzone verlassen
sogar uns selbst neu kennenlernen für
uns unsere mitmenschen und die welt eine
win win situation schaffen
wie also können wir auch angesichts des
klimawandels all diesen ansprüchen
gerecht werden
wir müssen weiter diese gespräche führen
wir müssen weiter das öffentliche
bewusstsein schärfen für ökologisch und
sozial verantwortliches reisen und das
heißt fernreisen tatsächlich verringern
auch wenn es zum teil auch bedauerlich
ist das bedeutet nach dem abenteuer der
haustür ausschau zu halten und das auch
als kreative herausforderung zu
begreifen und das glaube ich wird auch
nach der pandemie weiterhin eine
herausforderung sein
hand aufs herz wie aber schätzen lorenz
und brückner eine vernünftige flug
dosierung nach corona realistisch ein
der hunger rauszukommen und endlich
wieder diese erfahrung machen zu können
der ist so gewaltig dass ich glaube nach
der pandemie werden wir uns einfach hier
sozusagen die finger und reisen reisen
beruht auf möglichst großen ökonomischen
unterschieden zwischen den denjenigen
die reisen und diejenigen die bereist
werden weil es bei ihnen ein echter ist
als bei den leuten mit mehr geld wenn
diese unterschiede aufrechterhalten
bleiben in der härte wie wir sie heute
haben wird das reisen weitergehen
und wenn das erdöl weiter billig bleibt
das ist das alles ermöglicht dann wird
das reisen auch weitergehen welt wach
bleiben verantwortungsvoll das will erik
lorenz valentin grüttners maxime
verschlammten stadt verplanen
sein nächstes projekt mit dem fahrrad
ans meer
das ist richtig schön ist's passiert
überhaupt nichts man radelt am kanälen
entlang und hat einen großen großen
sommer je langsamer man unterwegs ist
desto größer ist das sommer
[Musik]
mir gefällt es hier draußen sogar bald
diesem bett da ich bin fürs erste im
luzernischen geblieben warum denn in die
ferne schweifen
[Musik]
zwischenstation machen wir hier am
rankbach am fuße des pilatus und um
berge geht es auch bei uns im nächsten
beitrag wenn auch in einem land das kaum
jemand auf seiner reise wunschliste
führen dürfte nordkorea bekannt aus
diktatur dass seine bevölkerung
unterdrückt und dem westen mit
atomwaffen droht doch nordkorea ist auch
ein land der berge ein team des alpinen
museums bern ist ins land der sehr
begrenzten möglichkeiten gereist
nordkorea
eine abgeschottete diktatur führerkult
unterdrückung armut
und doch hat das verarmte land etwas das
es auszeichnet und mit der schweiz
verbindet berge
nordkorea ist dreimal so groß wie die
schweiz und besteht zu 80 prozent aus
hügeln und bergen von dieser
gemeinsamkeit profitierten bächler
direktor des alpinen museums in bern und
der filmemacher dann so nah
ihre ausstellung über nordkoreas berge
will den stereotypen blick auf das
isolierte land mit neuen einsichten
erweitern
das stroh im kopf dass des ortes
nordkorea ist einfach nordkorea also
welches politische system
wer das land wo berger etzelsberger
einfaches geologisches phänomen sondern
sind mit identität verknüpft mit politik
mit geschichte kulturhistorisch und in
nordkorea ist es durch ihr politisches
sehr spürbar die ganze zeit
es sollte ihr bisher aufwendigste
projekt werden
2018 und 2019 noch vor corona begab sich
das schweizer team zweimal ins land der
begrenzten möglichkeiten eng begleitet
von guides des regimes jeder schritt
zuvor abgesprochen
jeder kontakt zu gesprächspartnern von
cultural komitee in pyongyang abgesegnet
dennoch kommt es zu spontanen interviews
etwa mit privilegierten einheimischen
touristen auf dem kumgang seien an der
grenze zu südkorea der ungefragte dank
an die großen führer ein immer
wiederkehrendes muster in den gesprächen
die das schweizer team in nordkorea
führte will eigentlich das kollektiv im
vordergrund
politische korrektheit
der peg tucson mit rund 2750 metern
höchste berg des landes gipfel der
indoktrinierung alle müssen einmal hier
oben gewesen sein
der berg ist besetzt von personenkult um
die herrscherdynastie der kim familie
und wird glorifiziert als wiege des
unabhängigkeitskampfes gegen fremde
mächte
[Musik]
die politische mystifizierung beginnt
schon im frühesten kindesalter und geht
nahtlos weiter in der schulischen
erziehung
den jetzt 11
wo die luft dünner wird schwebt der
geist des sozialismus nordkoreanischer
prägung
man stärkt den revolutionären glauben im
himmel sei alles hier verströmt eine
beinahe heilige aura
[Applaus]
manches in der ausstellung klingt
unbeholfen heruntergeleitet bestätigt
die vorurteile und doch beginnt man sich
für die menschen zu interessieren
wie sind sie angezogen wie frei können
sie sich überhaupt bewegen was denken
sie wirklich filmen durften die macher
eben nur was dem regime genehm war die
spielregeln waren von anfang an klar
gelingt es über das thema berge näher an
die menschen heranzukommen
es geht auf name in der berger im
stadtpark und plötzlich überrascht ist
wie ein licht das muss aber es geht auch
viel moment wo meditations- potenzial
hand und wo man baut er verstrickt
zwischen bürgern politik sehr spürt und
was dieser gewichtigste stadt selber
nicht einfach zu kommentieren oder
zweiter sondern wirklich die frage wo es
ständig auf begleiteten den ganzer
realisation prozess die afro gewitters
gehe an die suche in uns woche und das
sagt er diesen kurs der twitter
stattfindet wo ich meinen stuhl darüber
dass das auch nordkorea ist wo du zeit
bestätigen
und das ist ein leader permanent
abkommen selber gemacht und ich glaube
dass mir mein geschaut realisiert dass
mir eigentlich schon extrem wenig nervös
auch wenn es schwierig war an die
menschen heranzukommen ein ski resort
wie dieses sagt viel aus über ein land
das sich abschottet und doch zur welt
dazu gehören will
in dieser architektonischen einöde
erlebt das team einen seltenen moment
eines persönlichen bekenntnissen
es gibt sie die sehnsucht über die
eigenen berge hinauszuschauen
doch wie stark lässt sich die begrenzung
der diktatur im kopf überwinden was weiß
man ein für nordkorea weil nordkorea
über die welt die korona krise hat die
isolation nordkoreas noch verstärkt ein
glücksfall in diese seltenen eindrücke
eintauchen zu können
[Musik]
denn so rasch wird eine solche reise
wohl nicht mehr möglich sei
[Musik]
hier habe ich mein plätzchen gefunden
irgendwo im luzerner hinterland habe ich
einen lieben bauer gefragt der mir seine
visa zur verfügung stellt
[Musik]
und jetzt reisen wir in die
vergangenheit in die gloriosen zeiten
der schweizer hotellerie
wer es sich leisten konnte reiste zur
kur in der ersten hälfte des letzten
jahrhunderts war besonders gerne ins
engadin ein hotspot des badetourismus
war das prächtige hotel waldhaus in
vulgärer 1989 brannte es ab aber etwas
überlebte den brand nämlich die
gästekarte mit 20.000 karten
[Musik]
27 mai 1989 kurz vor sechs uhr früh
das hotel waldhaus in volterra steht in
flammen und brannte bis auf die
grundmauern nieder
wer hätte jedem einschlug mir hängt ist
denn du dir keller gearbeitet und bin
richtig wo man für kürten einer spritze
bist ein mitarbeiter die kommt aus
utrecht keller aber und zeit irgendwie
immer spritzer essig bereits in
vollbrand
32 jahre später bleiben die relikte ein
paar säulen schalen und eine mauer
[Musik]
das waldhaus war ein fünf sterne luxus
betrieb ein coupé mit 300 betten und 300
angestellten geöffnet jeweils von mai
bis september
er baut ende des 19 jahrhunderts vom
schweizer architekten niklas hartmann
bot es alle nur erdenklichen
annehmlichkeiten für die internationale
uli das war einfach ein schmelztiegel
treffpunkt und die hatten ja ganz weite
anreisen
ganze welt gekommen vor allem südamerika
und afrika johannes popp es nicht
glauben können dass sie sind ballsicher
und getreten haben allein von landeck
haben die acht stunden mit der
postkutsche gebraucht bis sie im
unterengadin angekommen sind
der mondäne betrieb florierte das image
stieg stetig die illustren gäste blieben
wochenlang intern wurde die klientel von
personal dabei kritisch beobachtet
belauscht bespitzelt und dieses
betriebsinterne wissen wurde auf den
karteikarten der gäste in einer art
blacklist notiert kurz scharf und
mitunter zynisch
[Musik]
jahrzehnte lagerten die karteikarten der
jahre 1921 bis 1961 externen und konnten
so den flammen entkommen
verschiedene geheimcodes mussten die ski
fährt werden recherchen des fotografen
des hechenblaikner und der
kulturwissenschaftlerin andrea kühbacher
ergaben dass die abkürzung tiroler für
jüdische gäste und ihre
geschäftstüchtigkeit verwendet wurde und
auch das kürzel pi mit den steigerungs
formen verwendet für palästina schweizer
zeugt von einer deutlichen
antisemitischen haltung des personals
die namen sind nicht geschwärzt weil
hinter den namen personen stehen und
geschichten stehen und es ist ja nicht
wichtig was über die leute gesagt wurde
ob das jetzt wahr ist oder nicht weil es
das können wir nicht überprüfen sondern
wir können nur sehen wie wurden sie
wahrgenommen und wie hat man sie
eingeschätzt und das sagte viel mehr
über den schreiber der karteikarten aus
als über den beschriebenen es geht hier
darum was für merke ich was aber richtig
bei anderen auch in den dreißiger jahren
des letzten jahrhunderts vor und während
des zweiten weltkriegs verkehrten juden
im waldhaus
zur gleichen zeit wie die nazis es
treffen die henker auf ihre späteren
opfer bis dann die juden ganz ausbleiben
ich finde karte stadions interessanter
wie sind nur mit bleistift wird stadt
reist und liefert eine karte und wenn
man das musst du dir denn die habe ich
da in der hand die hände nahm und den
einfach mit dem adresse
er ist ob sie wieder trister jahre und
am ende statt einfach mit bleistift
verreist ist ein menge von der kraft
nicht mehr nachgegangen
und wenn dann einfach müssen feststellen
dass irgendein verein lager und bracht
worden sind und das stimmt schon
nachdenklich
waldhaus gast war auch der schweizer
schriftsteller friedrich dürrenmatt
erholte sich im kot helfe seinen letzten
1989 erschienenen roman durcheinander
tal maßgebliche inspirationen also
durcheinander ding ja die wirklichkeit
sogar mit ihren fantasie durch da brennt
ein hotel ab in tarasp ja das war das
natürlich weil wir eigentlich dort hatte
ich die idee bei ihnen prinzip uns
wirklich abgebrannt eine explosion
erschütterte die nacht eine stichflamme
schoss in den himmel die sterne
verschwanden das ganze haus stand mit
einem mal in flammen der damalige
direktor glaubte nicht an einen zufall
es gibt das zu erfahren dass einen das
buch schrieb das buch wert war monate
nach dem brand wissentlich uns huus
brennt ab in der seite burschenschafter
schoolnet irmgard verhaftet weil eine
menge dienst bietet seit der ex husar
cent und das habe ich habe das nicht
sein
ich sage es geht zu erwarten fakt ist
dürrenmatt entwarf seine geschichte
jahrzehnte vorher
das waldhaus war immer schon treffpunkt
nicht nur für literatur giganten die
geheimen karteikarten sind zeugnisse mit
sprengkraft eine art dna der
tourismuswirtschaft mit emotionen und
krimispannung gespickt die rund
zehnjährige projekt recherche des
tiroler fotografen zum buch ist eine art
fantasie beflügeln maschine ein hotel
ist einfach immer auch ein
geheimnisträger weil das kann man so
will geschichten zusammen menschen die
aufeinander prallen immer in einer
anderen konstellation mit dem personal
und wo menschen sind müssen geschichten
bleiben
bleibt zu klären warum eigentlich keine
ostergrüße mehr notiert wurde
dieser code stand für maximalen
liebesentzug und garantierte dieser gast
kommt sicher nicht mehr
ich mache es mir hier ein bisschen
gemütlich heute abend und sie dann
morgen weiter mark twain übrigens er hat
ja das luzernische auch geliebt und von
ihm stammt der satz wir müssen reisen um
zu lernen das geht auch ohne flugzeug
wieder vielleicht heute dazufügen
nächste woche da zeigen wir ihnen die
besonderheiten der diesjährigen
oscar-verleihung und gleich jetzt geht
es weiter mit der dänischen serie die
wege des herrn des baltisches
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos